c'est très simple on jarry et on va
regarder ce qu'il ya dans la cabine à et
tu vas devoir dire aux téléspectateurs
ce que tu vois
ok d'accord ils vont devoir dire qu'ils
bluffent de nous deux d'accord c'est que
c'est une séquence que vous attendent à
chaque fois je vais tu veux démarrer ou
tu veux je démarre comme tu le sens bâti
mon chéri des marques et la regarde ce
que tu vois je prends le temps mon chéri
et je le dis maintenant ce que j'ai vu
ouais j'ai vu gilles alma déguisé en
astérix qui qui a un chat entre les
mains et qui est en train de maltraiter
d'accord faut pas maltraiter des animaux
non et s'il vous plaît pas qu'est ce que
vous faites vous pour empêcher quelqu'un
que vous connaissez pas voilà vous
rencontrez quelqu'un
et qu'est ce que vous faites mathieu
devant mon âge je veux pas des roses ça
c'est sûr
qu'est ce que je fais ah non mais j'y
vais directement
bah oui dites quoi j'ai envie de toi
rien ne laissait pas la personne
absolument
j'ai envie de toi ça déstabilise
d'entrée mais après ils vont fait péter
s'orienter contournement physique ça
marche assez souvent ah oui oui j'ai lu
chan en boîte de nuit je ne recommande
pas cette technique et gilles verdez
aujourd'hui il est en cours mais toi pas
[Applaudissements]
c
moi jouir ce que je vois et moi bien je
vous le jure il ya thierry beccaro en
train de jouer avec ses boules alors à
votre avis les airs il a erré labeouf
cyril bloc
je suis alors je suis sincère quand
garçons on peut se défendre ou comment
ça se passe alors vous pensez quoi vous
il cyril vous bluffez vous j'ai vu dans
les yeux de jarry la sincérité
ah ouais et dans les messieurs la
fausseté géraldine maillet voulons
envoyer un bouquin j'écris un livre moi
benjamin roure aux deux mois sera ma
maman m'a annoncé qu'on peut nier cela
oui une fois aux lieux anciens vous
sortez votre merci
et là il est avec nous ce soir c'est
notre ami j
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous c'est de la faire rire
ajout d'un conseil reste à une autre
fois c'est mon frère mais vous moi je
parle pendant des heures pour la salle
et ça marche à la fin ouais mais jack
c'est le mec vous connaissez tous les
gars comme ça que tous les matins à
l'usure à lire les meufs à la maison
peuvent tellement profond pas dit c'est
quoi vas-y tu es sur moi là et barre toi
vite après c'est vrai ça marche bien
[Rires]
alors je vais te tu veux vous dire je
vais vous dire ce qu'il ya derrière il y
à une star internationale qui fait de la
boxe
quand je vous dis une star
internationale il y a mike tyson
derrière soi le poker daniel vous moi
j'envoie agathe et au moment fatidique
on éteint la lumière et c'est la
surprise
moi comme toujours depuis 25 ans je fais
un chèque
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est que c'est qui jamais on a fait
toute cette séquence que pour sa
résistance et merci mon chéri versus et
du cpie de l'équipe
c'est notamment grâce à la demande